you've known our next guest since she
was a teenage actor alongside her
identical twin sister but did you know
that she can tear it up on the dance
floor She consults that she can swing
it's Tamara Maury Housley
[Applause]
I love you
I am in love with your outfit oh it
stinks it's like my New York Vibe like
Chic oh my fast did I pass are you like
I'm drooling oh thank you I don't know
if that's a pass or inappropriate but
I'm doing it oh well thank you you know
it's so fun we were at a karaoke night
you remember this well it's so funny
because I like I feel like I brag to my
kids all the time that I know Seth
MacFarlane who created Family Guy also
American Dad yep um
Ted like I mean there's nothing this man
can't do I know and back in the day
um we used to go to this place like the
Brass Monkey was that it and like yeah
I'm so happy you remember this and we
would go with Seth and he sings like um
he sings on the show all the time and he
sounds like Frank Sinatra yeah pretty
much like identical yeah and I am so
horrible at karaoke
um but I'm so glad that we got to share
in those times they were so free and fun
we actually
saying do you remember that we we sang
These Boots are Made for Walking
together I wanted to go up but I was
afraid and you were standing right by me
and I was like I don't want to do this
by myself I don't want to do this by
myself and uh I was with the guy who's
now my husband Adam yes yes Adam Housley
and he was like just ask Drew just just
ask her to just sing with you and I did
and you were like okay and we went up
there yeah and I'll never forget it it
was so yes I know I know that was only
like 10 years ago
I know I will be your wingman like any
day of the week are you kidding me you
guys heard it first I mean I'm so glad
you're here you are in this incredible
new book thank you I'm so proud of it
I'm so proud but it was actually
therapeutic too it was very therapeutic
because I talk about you know my my the
trials that I went through that you know
in Hollywood there's lots of rejection
and then when you are a child star
transitioning into you know
um an actress as an adult sometimes it
could be challenging and uh whoo we
survived thank God I mean it's amazing
to do that it is and uh you know as I
mentioned before it was therapeutic
writing the book because there were some
things that I thought that I had gotten
over and the main thing was the
insecurity it's amazing how the
rejection that you that you deal with
manifests in this crazy you know
um insecurity and that sometimes can can
mess with you and one of my tamericisms
in my book is I say you are the one who
defines you and I feel like that is what
has helped just my family we didn't let
the critics we didn't let the naysayers
we didn't let the reviews we didn't let
the lack of jobs Define who we are as
people and that's really important you
define who you are that's my life Mantra
of how to handle all the stuff that life
will hand you I mean you're you and your
sister did Sister Sister
um
which was a huge Juggernaut of a show
look at how cute
I can't even handle it yes that's my boo
she's my best friend I mean and like do
you ever consider doing because it was
such a I know what you're gonna say
right the word reboot
everybody have has asked that and we
want to
um it just I think everything has to
line up and we don't want because sister
sister was so iconic we don't want the
reboot to be like lame because then
that's what people are going to remember
so if we do do it it's gonna be
fantastic it has to be fantastic is it
true that you guys are the ones who came
up with the idea for the show it is we
didn't even know we were little
producers how I mean that's incredible
entrepreneurial I know we met this
amazing woman Irene Dreyer and we sat in
her office and for the first time a
producer actually asked us is there
something that you would want to do and
we were like huh okay she was like if
there was a show out there about twins
what would you want it to be you know
like and it was like a mixture of Parent
Trap and Sweet Valley High and sister
sister was born I mean you had me at
parents right that's my generation yeah
100 one other thing that I loved in this
book is the spicy
um list you have with your husband I
know I hear that's like the Talk of the
Town right now
um but I wanted to talk about it because
I am just naturally a very sensual
person right and when you get married
and you've been married too much just
listening okay
seven years
well this is the thing okay I have sex
goals and I think it's really important
to let women know it's okay to have that
it's okay to ask for what you want and
hopefully yes and hopefully your partner
we'll listen to that and it matches your
your energy so I talk about the things
that I have done and would like to do
sex is important so that's in a
relationship if you're very sensual and
you like it which I can tell
you like it
when I start dating again can I call you
absolutely okay I'm dead serious about
that
[Music]